UFOs have captivated the public interest
for decades but they've always been
dismissed including by me as the
province of wackos but that is changing
thanks to some remarkable videotape and
first-hand accounts from very sober
people who are trained to identify
aircraft and that would include this
video it shows two Navy pilots
encountering something bizarre off the
east coast of the United States watch
this
[Music]
okay these are guys who fly for a living
who know what other airplanes look like
including those maintained by foreign
governments and they're totally shocked
by this this is one among many incidents
like it including many that have
happened in the middle of the day to
sober people lots of independent
witnesses at the same event in
commercial pilots military pilots O'Hare
Airport in the afternoon none of them
have obvious explanations these are
aircrafts apparently that are moving in
ways that appear to violate physics that
are flying very differently from any
aircraft ever observed and way faster
than any plane that we know any foreign
country has what is this well we don't
know because for some reason the Defense
Department he's not interested in
finding out Lu Elizondo is a former
Pentagon official he helped research
UFOs he said the DoD is not taking any
of this seriously for some reason mr.
Elizondo joins us tonight good to see
you thank you for having so did I
overstate that is there a growing corpus
of evidence not drunk people on a lonely
rural road at 3:00 in the morning but
sober military pilots saying something
that we can't explain is happening that
is correct you're talking about
individuals who have very high security
clearances they are trained observers
we've actually paid them and put them
through schools to be trained and very
keen observers to scrutinize what
they're seeing these are individuals who
we trust to fly weapons platform
sometimes with LiveView munitions over
US cities and to fight and win wars on
our behalf and they're reporting to us
that they're seeing something that they
can't explain and it's also being backed
up by the video evidence and the radar
data and other witnesses but these must
just be weather balloons right well
weather balloons that are expressing
technologies that are far beyond our
current understanding of aerodynamics
things that are maneuvering in ways that
no aircraft that we are currently aware
of has that capability to flight
performance characteristics that are
well beyond the threshold of what we
would consider I think normal or routine
for for aircraft so they have no flight
surfaces no wings or anything
approaching a wing and there's also no
obvious propulsion so infrared doesn't
pick up any jet trail or rocket exhaust
coming out of these things right
plume you know there's there's many ways
to tie propulsion you can do it with a
jet engine for example a propeller or
rocket engine in this particular case
you have objects that are doing things
maneuvering in ways without any obvious
sign of propulsion and and defying the
natural effects of Earth's gravitational
at what speed well some are very very
very fast faster than our aircraft and
absolutely hypersonic speeds and by the
way without any obvious signs or
signatures involved so when an object is
moving through the atmosphere you would
expect it to have certain signatures
associated with that particular aircraft
whether it's a missile drone rocket so
for example you might see a heat
signature coming from you might see
ionization of the atmosphere
you might hear a sonic boom which you
normally would it's an acoustic
signature in this particular case these
objects don't have any of those
signatures so we know that they're not
US military because they wouldn't be
flying near US military aircraft as they
so often have and it seems like we would
know if foreign countries had that
acknowledged look I have no idea what it
is the bottom line is this is a
potential threat a grave one to our
country what does DoD doing about it
well I can't speak on behalf of DoD
right now because I'm no longer employed
as a Department of Defense employee but
I can't speak to what they were doing
about it and what they weren't doing
about it when I was part of the program
I think DoD is a very large complex
organization I think it's very good at
what it normally does but in this
particular case we had a very
ill-defined problem set and so when
you're going to the boss and you say
look boss we have we have something here
we don't know what it is we sure don't
know how it works and by the way there's
nothing we can do about it that is a
very difficult conversation to have in
an organization that is it's the sole
mission is national security it's just I
think it's just I think it's terrifying
I mean this seems potentially like one
of the biggest stories of my lifetime
and I don't care if it's about UFOs or
whatever you call it something that we
don't understand is getting very close
to our military aircraft and the
government isn't responding adequately
and I hope you keep sounding the alarm
on this yeah I think if I may just very
quickly we got 10 seconds ok you go to
the metro you see a sign see something
say something and we
we gotta Adam way for reporting it in
this particular case these pilots who
are seeing something in this back to buy
other data it's nothing it's terrifying
that's that's the essence of dysfunction
Lou thank you for that I hope you sir
come back